[موسيقى]
بالطبع يمكنني قيادة أي سيارة على طول
كورنيش الريفييرا الفرنسية ولكن
بالنسبة لهذا البريطاني أريد أن أضيف لمسة من
الأصالة ونعم Anglo Pride لذلك فأنا
أقود سيارة من طراز الستينيات من القرن الماضي
Jag the الحلق
الزئير n في موناكو  مونت كارلو، كيف
سيأخذني الطريق مباشرة على طول
الريفييرا، وفي النهاية سأذهب إلى إيطاليا
اليوم، سأذهب فقط إلى مونت
كارلو
الجميلة، هذا هو ما أتيت هنا من أجله،
انظر
إلى اليخوت الرائعة جدًا يا
ثنائي  اللغة الفرنسية
مفيدة للغاية، يمكن أن أقضي الصيف
هنا الآن فقط يجب أن أجد شخصًا يدفع ثمنه
[موسيقى] [
تصفيق]
كما تعلمون هذا الخط مونت كارلو أو تمثال
نصفي أوه هنا مونت كارلو أعتقد أنه لا
يزال لدي بعض المال  تركت في جيبي
وهو
إنجاز، أنا دائمًا أشعر بالرهبة من موناكو،
الإمارة ذات التراث الملكي
التي تقف مستقلة نوعًا ما عن
فرنسا، هذا هو المكان الذي يأتي فيه الأغنياء حقًا
[موسيقى]
هناك سبب لتوافد الناس
هنا و  المناخ المعتدل ليس
سوى جزء منه لأن الجميع
يتحدث حقًا عن ضوء جميع
الرسامين الانطباعيين والفرنسيين،
وربما يكون ماتيس هو الأكثر
ارتباطًا بالسلام ونورها الشهير
الذي جاء إلى هنا في
عام 1917 ووقع للتو في حب المنطقة
وفنها  تتحدث فلورنس تورير المتحمسة
عن سيد الفن HRI
matis، لقد تمت زيارة المتحف بشكل جيد بالتأكيد،
لكن أنا وفلورنسا أتينا
إلى هنا لرؤية لوحة معينة، لذا فإن
هذا يسمى tet anise وهو ما يعني
العاصفة في N، وهذه هي زيارته الأولى في n،
وكانت  دمره المطر المستمر لمدة
شهر كامل ولكن في صباح اليوم التالي
هبت الرياح الغامضة الغيوم وجاء
هذا الضوء المذهل إلى البحر
والسماء وقرر البقاء لبقية
حياته حيث تم
أخذه منه  pr من فندق P
mediterran والذي أصبح الآن فندقًا،
ويمكننا أن نرى أنه لا يزال بإمكاننا رؤية VI
اليوم الآن، ولم يكن فندق High Hotel موجودًا هنا في
عام 1920 عندما رسم هذه الصورة، ولكني
أعتقد أنه قريب جدًا من المكان، نعم
بالضبط، لذلك هم  ربما يكون عدد
الأشجار قد تغير خلال
المائة عام الماضية ولكن هذا هو المكان الذي
كان هنا في فندق بي ميديتيران ميديتيران
في ذلك الوقت لرسم هذه اللوحة ولكن
الطقس اليوم أكثر روعة
مما رآه في هذا
ماتيس جميل كان لديه غرفة في البحر الأبيض المتوسط
واستخدمها كاستوديو لبعض الوقت كيف
يمكنك الحصول على الماء من هذا المنظر كان هناك
الكثير منهم يرسمون هنا
في ذلك الوقت لم يكن هناك نعم
بالضبط كانت فترة أم  من الناحية
الفنية أه أم الفرح وأه كان هناك
الكثير من التجمعات الكبيرة للفنانين
وليس فقط أي فنان قديم ظهر هنا،
العظماء كانوا في حضوره
ريمور وبيكاسو مون وشاجال
في جميع أنحاء الوزير بأكمله، يمكنك
تحديد الأماكن التي ألهمت
الفنانين  والتي تم استخدامها كديكور
ونموذج أه للمناظر الطبيعية
للوحات مختلفة يمكننا رؤيتها كثيرًا
كيف يمكننا أن نضع أنفسنا في
مكانهم ونفهم لوحاتهم بشكل أفضل
هناك منطقة
جذب سياحي غير معروفة تسمى
الفنان  الطريق إذا كنت ستتبع
الطريق يمكنني زيارة الأماكن التي
ألهمت اللوحات الشهيرة لذلك
أغادر وأتوجه إلى قرية التلال في قرية
بول ديفانس نحن الآن حقًا في
أعماق الريف هنا نعم
بول ديفانت جميل ونسمع  صوت
السيتا ليس أنهم في حالة حرب تقريبًا،
نعم بصوت عالٍ إلى أين نحن ذاهبون، سنرى إلتر اه
يعرض
لوحة من مارك شاجل الذي أحب هذه
القرية الصغيرة في منزل هنا وقضى
السنوات الأخيرة من حياته  يا
إلهي، لقد قمت برفع القلب نوعًا ما،
أليس كذلك عندما تنظر إلى
أوه نحن نفهم سبب أهمية هذا الضوء
بالنسبة لهم
والألوان المتغيرة التي أخبرتك أنهم يحبون نورها
هنا أوه الآن انظر هنا نحن  اذهب
لزوجين آخرين، مارك شاجيل لا دي فاج، إلى الطاولة
أمام القرية، وهذا هو
المكان الذي حصل فيه على الإلهام من نعم،
هناك العديد من هؤلاء الفنانين
واللوحات المثيرة للاهتمام المنتشرة في
جميع أنحاء الكثير من المدن التي لها
تاريخها الخاص  لذلك في مون لديك jto
in biot لديك Fern Le in anti
لديك Picasso V هو حقًا Mar shagal um
SLE Dev أنا أحب
هؤلاء، يجب أن يفعلوا المزيد منهم، فهو
يضيف شيئًا إلى نزهتك، نعم
يمنحك شيئًا لتكتشف
شيئًا بالضبط  تعميق فهم
هذه المنطقة بأكملها، والتباطؤ للاستمتاع
بالمنظر، شكرًا جزيلاً لكم، لم تضيع
مني مرة أخرى متعة بسيطة
للريفيرا الفرنسية التي تجلب الفرح الحقيقي
[موسيقى]